[Music]
if you got a chance to play neo in one
of its to trial periods last year and
you've been wanting another go at the
action RPG then you'll be happy here you
get one more chance before launch I'm
Matt and you can demo this game spot
news update right now the dark souls
like neo is getting its final demo
available to everyone from january 21st
to the 22nd the demo is available to
preload from the playstation store right
now and will be playable for a 48-hour
period completing the trial earns you a
number of bonus prizes that you'll be
able to use in the full game these
include the ogres headgear and the mark
of the conker and mark of the strong DLC
packs make sure to hold onto that save
file if you want your rewards Neil
releases on februari 9th exclusively for
the PlayStation 4 Team Ninja recently
confirmed that pvp multiplayer will come
to the action game but it won't be
available at launch we'll keep you
updated as more as announced so for that
and more news from the world of video
games stay tuned to GameSpot's